Good morning John, I am currently in Haiti.
No, I'm in my office, but by the time you
see this, I will be in Haiti. So I'm pre-recording
this video because I'm not gonna have internet
connection while I'm in Haiti.
And people have been asking me to make a video
about the science of zombies, so I thought
that I would get that out of the way right
now.
There is no science of zombies! There has
never been, nor will there ever be - an undead
creature.
Life is an extraordinarily complicated balance
of inputs and outputs and temperatures and
reactants and wastes and fuels, and if any
of that stuff breaks down, none of it works.
Homeostasis - look it up, and then stop worrying
about zombies.
But this does lead me to an interesting thought:
How, in fiction, are supernatural beings created?
And what does that say about the people who
write those stories and the people who are
interested in those stories?
So zombies, for example, are generally created
by disease. Just like rabies, you get bit,
you get the disease, you get sick, you go
crazy and then you die, and then you un-die
and then you, yourself, become a vector for
the disease.
There are other examples for disease-based
conversion from natural to supernatural, uh,
werewolves being another one like zombies,
but also vampires.
Now vampires get their power from a disease,
but it seems very different from zombies,
and it is in fact, quite different from zombies
because zombies are a disease based in violence;
whereas vampires are a disease based in romance-sexy-time.
Which kinda makes sense why women are more
interested in the vampires stuff, and the
men are more interested in the zombie stuff,
because it's like action movies versus chick-flicks.
Except that supernatural monsters version
of that argument.
But all of this is pretty unsurprising because
sex, and disease and violence, probably some
of the most important forces in the lives
of early humans, but newer myths, created
by fiction writers and a lot of comic writers
provide the same kind of insight.
Superheroes nowadays don't so much get their
power from disease and sex and violence, superheroes,
which began to be created in the 1930s or
so, get their power from things that we believe,
or believed, hold great power.
Spiderman is a great example, because once
upon a time, he got his powers from being
bitten by a radioactive spider, and that was
back when radioactivity and atomic power held
all this promise of potential, like, cheap
energy for everyone and also the potential
for the destruction of the entire world.
But then when Spiderman got revamped for the
next generation, they cut out the radioactivity
- cause that wasn't sexy any more - and instead
they put in a genetically modified spider.
And thus, we can say about ourselves as consumers
of content, that the aura of mystery and power
and fear that once surrounded radioactivity
and atomic energy now has moved over into
genetically modified stuff.
All these things that within our culture hold
a great deal of power and mystique, like money
and technical expertise and the government
as a hero and the government as a villain,
atomic power, outer-space, the internet, particle
physics, our genes, our brains - our obsession
with all these things have grown and waned
over the years, as has their use in the creation
of superheroes.
And of course, John, in your zombie apocalypse
novella, you did this very thing - you took
a source of power and fear and mystery for
humanity, the genetic engineering of crops,
and you mixed it with the existing zombie
myth to get zombies who died and then liked
to plant lots of corn. You fell directly into
the archetype, like everybody else. Of course,
everyone falls in the archetype - that's what
archetypes are for.
So I'm always keeping my eye out for new and
unique ways that superheroes are being created,
because I think it's a really clear indicator
of what we're becoming obsessed with and what
we're becoming afraid of.
For example, there's a new movie coming out
in which an out of work writer takes this
pill, and he becomes a super-genius, and of
course, this reflects our fear and fascination
about what is going on with brain chemistry
and pharmaceuticals.
Superheroes and other super natural beings
are, of course, fictional, and they seem like
they're just there for fun, but they do provide
us, I think, with a great opportunity to analyze
ourselves and what we're becoming obsessed
with and what we're becoming afraid of.
Interestingly, those two things - often the
same thing.
So it's nice to see that this entire shelf
of science fiction here, in fact, allows me
to learn more about us as humans.
John, I'll see you on Monday.